foreign  [Music]  moves fast one day you're playing Kick  the Can with kids named flick and  Schwartz I  the next thing you know you're a  certified adult  Ralph dear old man  he was the best  grumpy promise me we're gonna make this  a wonderful Christmas that would make  your father so happy I promise  what have I done and that was all up to  me I suggest you start drinking and  don't stop till New Year's  [Music]  the kids who wants to go see Santa this  is amazing incredible we will meet you  right here when you're done don't let  him kick you in the face  when it's just us decorating it kind of  feels like child labor honey it's not  labor if we don't pay you yeah  cheers  my dad made this all look so easy  that doesn't mean it was easy  [Music]  [Applause]  that's brutal It's the Most Wonderful  Time slowly I could feel the Christmas  Ember beginning to Glow again  foreign  [Music]